[Musique]
ces policiers d'un autre temps font de
la reconstitution
la moustache pas un hasard du tout à
l'époque c'était une obligation elle
permettait d'asseoir une certaine
autorité qu'on veut surtout attrapé si
j'ose dire
à travers cette mesure de couvre feu
c'est tout ce qui a fait progresser le
virus dans ces régions c'est à dire les
rendez vous entre guillemets privé les
les parties les les anniversaires
c'est ma première
première surprise party chantait chela
en 63 expression devenue ringarde avant
même la naissance des manuels macro les
moments de convivialité on se retrouvait
à 50 et 60 des soirées festives
malheureusement parce que ce sont des
vecteurs d'accélération de ce virus et
l'angleterre comme carthage doit être
détruite
oui on va dans ma chaise quand même ce
soir la semaine prochaine j'ai déjà une
soirée prévue avec plein plein de
personnes parce qu'on va tous faire des
soirées quand même dans tous les cas et
ça va juste être privé et on continuera
à faire la fête dans tous les cas
quoiqu'il arrive alors c'est pas le bal
masqué ils ne sont pas d'eau à domont
j'avoue c'est un peu tristoune oh non
pas comme ça qu'on va faire les à le
faire la phrase qui te fait du bien et
que tu te répète au quotidien je boirai
pas d'alcool ce soir je n'aurais pas
d'alcool ce soir je bois pas d'alcool ce
soir
[Musique]
moche
les rangs
[Musique]
d
énorme coup de masse on met un coup de
massue ahurissant quand je vois tout
autour la la perfection avec laquelle
tous ces restaurateurs se soumettent
valable stylo pour prendre mon téléphone
je vois personnellement ils sont
remarquables et on les anéantit on vit
une chose ou on ne comprend pas c'est ça
qui est bien c'est qu'on ne comprend pas
ce que ce gouvernement fait le rappel
est assez important parce que l'effet
pervers de ces abus c'est que les
citoyens perdent confiance et finissent
par inscrire deux fois en 10 2 fois
identité pardon c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé encore une fois on a une
photo pamela anderson james bond est
incertain gilet jaune qui se sont
côtoyés côtoyé au même endroit ça peut
prêter à sourire mais les conséquences
peuvent être graves
merci professeur
[Applaudissements]
coupez c'est bon on les oblige pas
regarder les chaînes d'info à regarder
la télé avec ses infos et dès qu'il ya
un sujet sera dès qu'on parle de choses
nous propose de mettre des choses sur le
haut-karabagh cependant les gens ne
regardent pas donc ils sont demandeurs
quand on leur dit cache des choses
ils disent qu'on n'est pas transparent
j'ai pas en train de faire une espèce de
défense corporatiste donc à la fois ils
veulent savoir mais ça les effraie quand
ils savent ça leur fait peur il voudrait
de la liberté mais voudrait à la fois
l'état et de la sécurité être protégé je
pense qu'effectivement ça c'est
peut-être probablement en discutant
régulièrement tous ensemble on en
sortira ferme lors le centre de gravité
de la société française j'ai
l'impression ce moment est en train de
se déplacer vers la sécurité la
tranquillité et la forme de sérénité et
non pas vers la liberté ou risque à ses
risques et périls qui était certaine
époque a été une chose essentielle
bon maintenant on se dit est ce que le
spectateur va être bon très bon vous
exceptionnel voilà alors ça c'est
l'éternelle question est ce que c'est le
spectateur qui doit être bon est-ce que
c'est l'artiste qui doit aller chercher
les spectateurs pour qu'ils soient bons
dans ce spectateur qui le bon quand ça
quand ça arrive pas bien c'est que c'est
la faute du spectacle à la foule de
spectateurs un pic à la base quand on
s'est serré la main ce qu'on vient de
faire c'est un geste pacifique ça
voulait dire je n'ai pas d'armes tu n'as
pas d'argent à se faire la main là
aujourd'hui malheureusement serrer la
main là on vient de prendre un risque en
fait parce que potentiellement on peut
sa portée vient le virus et vous savez
bien stressant on ce mardi soir les rues
sont quasi désertes
les policiers ne font que de la
prévention
ce jeune couple échappent de peu à une
amende de 135 euros ou mes coups
moi je n'ai pas sur moi j'ai oublié dans
ma voiture je suis désolé c'est pas moi
j'ai géré ma jamais censuré sauf une
fois mais on n'a jamais c'était quand
c'était sur ces 8 parce que j'avais
interviewé la mecque du duc a un mec
était trahi au qatar et qui disait du
mal d'eux
du qatar et on m'a fait comprendre la
direction m'a fait comprendre comme il
était en train de signer avec bin il
fallait peut-être évité de dire du mal
du qatar c'est la seule fois de ma
carrière donc faut quand même le dire
j'ai fait les pires conneries jamais été
censuré sauf une fois voilà présente
devant moi en chant c'est un concours de
cuisine tu viens en short
pourquoi pro il est mis aux enchères un
peu fou et je pense qu'il a mûri de ce
fonds au lieu de 6 et lui fait du bien
darrigand tenu coi correct au moins pour
pas l'on parle un jour pourquoi tu viens
de bons mois avec un short
si faible non mais sérieux quoi il fait
beau et alors est ce que je te reçois
tombe - olivier veyrat est en fonction
depuis plusieurs mois
matin midi soir la nuit le week-end un
test devant vous il est toujours au
front toujours au front toujours il ne
ménage ni son temps ni sa grande
compétence et c'est un atout pour notre
pays
[Musique]
car il faisait un jogging quand il a
remarqué des bébés félins sur son chemin
problème la mer cougar est tout près
elle est très agressive l'eau le
randonneur se met à reculer et tente de
faire fuir l'animal par tous les moyens
dubuc critiquer mais l'insulté ne donne
pas grand chose et rugir ne fonctionne
pas non non
après six minutes d'angoissé le jeune
homme jette une pierre dans sa direction
et peut enfin souffler
2020 en un mot
une has on dit ce qu'on veut on dit ce
qu'on veut à la télé mais oui il faut le
dire aux gens et quoi tu veux si on dit
rien c'est parce qu'on n'a rien à dire